an eight-ton 45-foot sperm whale carcass
washes up on your beach what do you do
you can't move it the thing is falling
apart you can't bury it there's water
under the sand and can't throw back in
the ocean force the tides can push them
back in so I'd as well blow it up it was
an ordinary day in November 1970
November 12th 1970 to be exact
thanks Paul this year is Paul linman he
was a television reporter for Portland's
KATU and none of ember 12 1970 Paul was
assigned a story that would change his
life forever
what to do with 145-foot 8 ton whale
dead on arrival on the beach near
florence wales washing up on the beach
in oregon are not an uncommon occurrence
but it had been so long
state officials didn't know how to get
rid of that giant stinking carcass
that's precisely why the organ
department transportation decided to use
dynamite the plan was to blow the whale
into smaller pieces and have scavengers
like seagulls eat the rest of it Paula's
cameraman set up their shot and waited a
thousand yards away from the blast
within I'd say about 20 or 30 seconds it
was soon raining down on olives the
larger pieces that came down it became
louder and louder until you realize wow
if one of these chunks hits me I'm a
goner we start running in the direction
of the parking lot and that's when a
piece of blubber about the size of a
small coffee table completely flattened
an Oldsmobile Katie use exploding whale
report was a viral video in the
pre-internet age it's inspired parodies
and one-man shows and for Paul Inman
it's been career-defining it's something
that reoccurs in my life in one way or
another every single day I know what's
going to be written about in my obituary
[Music]